les vastes forêts entourant l'abitibi
témiscamingue sont en quelque sorte
devenu une barrière naturelle pour
lutter contre la coved 19 demeurer à
plus de 500 kilomètres des grands
centres est un avantage certain mais ça
n'explique pas tout selon la santé
publique
c'est une z en abitibi témiscamingue
c'est l'emplacement oui mais c'est aussi
la population de l'abitibi témiscamingue
je vois que tout le monde contribue nous
avons des citoyens qui veut protéger la
région
l'abitibi-témiscamingue ses 118 cas de
covile depuis le début de la deuxième
vague et aucune éclosion dans les écoles
garderies le mouvement anti masque a eu
bien peu d'ampleur et les mesures
sanitaires sont respectés par la
majorité des gens malgré la pandémie
l'économie se porte bien le moteur
économique de la région ce sont les
mines la bouche avec la lenteur en
arrière
et les entreprises ont pris les grands
moyens pour lutter contre la pandémie
certaines minières se sont même dotés de
leur propre laboratoire de dépistage
ils peuvent donc tester leurs employés
et recevoir les résultats en moins de 12
heures
c'est plus rapide que le système public
c'est devenu clairement une référence
alors même si on n'est pas dans
l'industrie minière
beaucoup d'entreprises ci se sont
conformés où se sont adaptés en fonction
des protocoles centech avait été adoptée
par par les mineurs ou en tout cas se
sont inspiré largement comme ceux des
protocoles qui sont très sérieux alors
ça a eu un effet sur toutes les
entreprises les chiffres lui donnent
raison
alors qu'au québec les lieux de travail
sont les endroits où il ya eu le plus
grand nombre de foyers d'éclosion il y
en a eu très peu en abitibi
témiscamingue le plus important avait
touché uniquement huit personnes dans la
région les restaurants et les bars sont
ouverts les jim et salles de spectacles
aussi si quelqu'un tomber malade et plus
de chances qu'on connaisse où c'est
peut-être plus plus évident plus concret
que dans un avenir ensemble par exemple
connaît en ce moment tout le monde je le
dis c'est vraiment la sensation tout
appartenait à une communauté veut pour
on n'est pas beaucoup de monde on n'est
pas beaucoup de personnes qui restent à
rouen la rando on y sent visée parce
qu'on connaît quelqu'un ok tamer a été
scellée c'est oui ok c'est ce qui fait
que ces puissances yves de connaître une
personne peut dors et malade demeurer
une zone jaune est en fait devenue la
principale motivation des gens à
respecter les règles sanitaires
certains le font aussi pour les enfants
la très grande majorité des parents sont
prêts à le faire pour que l'argent
continue à jouer au hockey piste est un
petit sacrifice à faire pour que
l'abitibi témiscamingue a pu tenir
dernièrement quelques festivals dont le
fmi et le festival international du
cinéma
les artistes sont aussi de plus en plus
nombreux à venir dans la région même
l'humoriste mike ward y enregistre ses
balades au devant public
la période des fêtes pourrait bien être
cruciale avec le retour des étudiants et
la venue possible de visiteurs la santé
publique leur demande d'ailleurs de
s'isoler pendant sept jours à leur
arrivée les commerçants font aussi leur
part
nous autour d'une grosse mission dont le
prix c'est de fermer pendant les fêtes
c'est la première fois qu'on fait en dix
ans j'arrête de défaite on veut pas des
gens qu'ils qui vient de l'extérieur se
maintenir au papier jaune est une source
de fierté de motivation pour les gens de
l'abitibi témiscamingue
malgré la hausse du nombre de cas
ailleurs au québec il souhaite que ce
système de palier soit maintenue
appliquer des règles de façon
unilatérale par tous seraient bien mal
reçue en abitibi témiscamingue
ici jean marc belzile radio canada ron
arad